there's no way these are spicier
well there's only one way to find out oh
god
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by khloe kardashian
she's a pop culture icon whose life is
back in the spotlight with the family's
brand new series the kardashians
currently streaming on hulu she's also
co-founder of the good american fashion
brand gotta keep an eye out for the
recently launched collaboration with
zara but in the meantime a 10-round bout
with the wings of death khloe kardashian
welcome to the show thank you for having
me i've heard that you have to be talked
into things whether it's something big
like snl the met gala and i'm just
curious who is it that talked you into
doing hot ones
well i'm sure a handful of people i mean
it's been about eight months since i've
agreed to do this and nothing personal i
don't take it personally don't eat
chicken i don't eat
hot sauce and i you know i have a lot of
anxiety with interviews in general so
but i'm here and i have my hot sauce
face on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you take like a real big bite
okay
okay
[Music]
that's fine
so after 14 years on e the kardashians
are now on hulu and we were so excited
to learn that you'd be bringing the
cameras along with you for this
interview from your vantage point as
reality tv creator are there things that
you notice like how the sausage has made
details when you're watching say the
real housewives that the rest of us may
miss watching from our couch
definitely i can tell when
some audio has been put in if they need
to like reshoot audio or if like a phone
call is faked or and not that those
things didn't happen but sometimes they
didn't catch the audio or sometimes the
mics go out or so i understand that a
lot of it might be really how it was
but they might just have to redo
something or transitions to thing or i
mean i even know that a lot of pages or
they're now like fan accounts will find
if they see like an editing issue or
something like that so it could be super
minor but i'm really aware of those
things and i tend to notice all that
stuff well speaking of heightened senses
are you ready to move on here to the
next wing island wings yup with the dobo
loco here in the two spot dobo logo lord
okay
[Music]
i'm going to spice here i think i got
this though
it leaves a little spicy tingling on my
lips but
that's good i'm fine
okay
so i want to congratulate you on your
brand new dream home so i want to
congratulate you on your brand new you
got it
stuck on the spice you know what it
doesn't matter how many times you go
through it you know nobody is completely
safe okay you know it can catch anybody
okay babe ruth struck out sometimes too
you know you're right michael jordan
missed some [ __ ] you're right
so i want to congratulate you on your
brand new dream home and what i have to
say is without hyperbole the most
organized and impressive kitchen pantry
i've ever seen in my life can you talk
us through the design process for the
pantry it's clear that you had a vision
i don't know if you're flirting with me
but that's the best flirting you could
ever give me complimenting my pantry
sure whatever you want you're gonna get
after this okay there we go um but um
yes i definitely have a vision i see how
other people organize things i might get
ideas and then i just make it my own
and my goal for my pantry is i didn't
want tons of plastic
and so i had to find like lazy susans
and i might have stained them if they
were came in one color would i stain
them a different color so i was a little
insane with making everything match and
super monochromatic
but i love a good organized anything
it's a big turn on for me as you can see
i don't know if this is like lingering
and getting hotter but i'm it's getting
a little hotter i don't know if it's you
or the wing
all right
or all the pantry talk oh my god i know
that's what i'm saying i think it's the
pantry talk let's uh crank up the heat
uh keep talking organization you might
have to defog that lens here before we
move on here to wing number three
this is the uh mezz clean here in the
third spot okay
lord
oh my god i'm only a number three
[Music]
i'm good here
okay
i'm proud of myself i got to three i'm
proud of you too hit that dj khaled line
you know right there three wings in okay
so your clothing line good american has
at the heart of the brand a mission to
make quality clothes for people of all
sizes what are the challenges of making
a size-inclusive clothing line like i
imagine you can't take every design and
scale it from like size double zero to
size 30.
we do oh my god maybe it is spicy
we do
i got this
at good american oh my god you guys
it's coming when you talk
so at good american we do everything
that we produce we have in the full size
range and we actually don't let
retailers carry good american unless
they promise to take the full size range
and that's a gift and a curse because
not everyone has the budget to carry
that wide of a size range but also it's
not fair for clothing stores department
stores to sort of dictate what they
think women should be wearing and what
size
it costs a lot more money and time to
have
different fabrications for different
shaped women and yeah it is much more
difficult to make something in a double
x
a double extra small to a 5x large
so it's a lot more that goes into it but
it's worth it
is there a key to pulling off a canadian
tuxedo like a do and a don't when it
comes to floor-to-ceiling denim god i
love the canadian texture
so um
i like when the denims match more it
almost looks like a full jumpsuit just
to sort of bleed into one another so i
don't know if there's a rule for that i
just think it's preference but canadian
tuxedo is always a vibe hey well if you
say it then it's gospel for me are you
ready to move on here to the fourth wing
you're doing so good okay good this is
the uh los calientes verde hey okay
[Music]
that's good
you're doing great okay you're doing so
good i think i got this oh wow there's a
kick after that okay
[Music]
do you have a go-to paparazzi evasion
tactic like have you ever played around
with prosthetics or disguises or stunt
doubles or anything like that oh my god
not stunt doubles but my sisters and i
did wear prosthetics and
my little sisters they
we had a childhood without cameras and
they didn't necessarily and so sometimes
they always wonder what if and i'm like
okay girls let's do a what if and so we
did prosthetics we went on like a tmz
type tour bus
and no one knew who we were at first and
then they started figuring out cuz our
act we like spoken accents for some
reason and we weren't solid the whole
time so i think we sort of don't ask me
to do that you blew your own they're not
good we blew our own cover
and um yeah but it was fun and that
stuff is it's fun but that's a lot of
work
i just try to avoid seeing them as much
as i can
okay the seventh reaper
okay
oh wow
[Music]
okay
oh my god i'm literally sweating
[Music]
but you're doing good i know that you
came in here with not much hot sauce
experience this has carolina reaper in
it that's probably that like deep pepper
that you're feeling for many years the
hottest pepper in the entire world and
look at you handling that no problem wow
yeah it's hot okay
all right chloe we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull the picture up over here on the
monitor and we have an all fitness theme
for khloe kardashian good i love that
all right first up dug into the archives
dug into the archives for this one where
does the let's get physical complex
cover where does it fall in your
pantheon of favorite khloe kardashian
magazine spreads it's definitely the top
five
i love that one
that might be the top three what i'm
sweating right now so it's hard for me
to count so i would say the top three
this was i think the first time i ever
did a cover that i was i would say
really sexy on i don't think i've ever
done another cover like that especially
with my butt being
more forward than my face and so it was
but i loved it i thought it was
just a good
empowering cover for me i felt really
good and confident
can you talk me through your back day in
as much detail as possible i'm gonna be
over here taking notes oh my gosh so
this um i've been working on more
chiseling my
my body i like muscle i don't just like
to be thin i think it's really
empowering and i get i feel a sense of
accomplishment after my workouts and
knowing i'm working on parts of my body
so yeah i mean you want like the real
step-by-step yeah yeah i mean you know
you can tell it was eight lifts or you
push pull like you know just give me
give me some some specifics we do push
and pull a lot but every time
for we start with cardio about five
minutes
and then we'll
either do full body days or we'll focus
on just upper and abs or lower and abs
abs are always involved but it's a
24-hour recovery with the abs you know
it's always so trainers love to just do
it every single day they love to do it
every day
but a lot of push-ups a lot of planks
we use a lot of weights nothing is
really just calisthenics it's sort of a
little bit of everything but are you
ready oh god to move on here to the back
half
this is the uh collard and ghost here
from hot and saucy oh my god this one
that's a 15 out of 10. you can't look at
it yeah yeah okay
don't psych yourself oh [ __ ]
oh
[Music]
god oh my gosh i'm really shorting
my eyes are crying
okay i'm with you
right with you too right with you too
so
one of the themes and we talked about it
a little bit in the intro of season one
of the kardashians is this anxiety that
you feel about doing interviews what are
your thoughts on how celebrity is
handled in the media these days
i'm listening sean i'm right here with
you and then what do you think has
changed the most in your nearly decade
and a half in the spotlight oh dear lord
um
how do people get the answers out i know
it's a mystery to me too
i mean
i don't even know what people take away
from this i'm like am i speaking english
to you
okay
i used to really enjoy doing interviews
and i would think it's fun and someone
might ask you questions you're never
asked before and that's exciting and i'm
always i think more dreading not the
interview i enjoy doing the interviews
it's the aftermath of what's going to
come who's going to chop this up and
make this into something that it wasn't
supposed to be and i think it just takes
the fun
out it takes um
the freedom of just talking so
conversationally and innocently and it
makes it so
thought out and premeditated and that's
just not to me that's not an i don't
like to overthink things too much i just
want to have a natural flow and
enjoy the conversation
huh
wow
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
yeah
that's a different level
[Music]
wow oh my god it's always after
whoa right there's sort of a time delay
on hot sauce i feel like crap
i'm right with you i'm right with you
finally
oh my god
oh okay
what are the hallmarks of a good hot
spot celebrity restaurant like is there
something about nobu malibu or craigs or
mr chow that makes him especially
conducive to dining while famous oh my
god they probably don't have this range
of hot sauce
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
i can do this so
[Music]
nobu is definitely
the atmosphere there's nothing like
having an early dinner i'm like crying
there is nothing like dinner on the
beach with that beautiful scenery and
you just i mean the food is so fantastic
as well but the ambiance is great
like the staff everyone is so sweet and
great i mean i always have great
experiences at these places so i don't
know
i really don't have a good answer for
you i'm also that is a good factor tears
i don't know if i'm even thinking
oh my god
[Music]
oh god
beyond insanity it's a bomb grape
[ __ ]
oh my god
oh shut up
right away
oh my god
oh you got the milk oh my god i know
why do people do that this is always a
part in the show i feel like i have to
apologize for
[Music]
holy [ __ ] i know i know it's a
completely different level
oh my god my heart's racing yeah it's uh
transcendent this sauce
[Music]
that is crazy
so you want to describe yourself as a
damn good hostess is there a cocktail
that you think would pair best with the
wings of death
[ __ ] i've literally cried
no i know it's fine
what's the point of this right now yeah
oh
i can't talk one minute take your time
take your time
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm saying
preach
oh my god
okay
it's the craziest thing i've ever had i
guess some tequila to kill ya
because this is gonna kill you first
holy [ __ ]
i'm not a big drinker these days but
when i do i go full throttle i'm not
drinking because
like i enjoy the taste i'm drinking
because i'm trying to
get somewhere here oh yeah
so
but no i normally just stick with
tequila or champagne or normally my two
choices of alcohol
wow
holy [ __ ] is that the spiciest thing
that you've ever eaten in your life i've
ever had in my life
there's no way these are spicier
well there's only one way to find out oh
god
oh god
i'm so proud of myself
the psycho hot sauce yep
from australia out of town from
australia we know it's going to be hot
oh my god
i got this two left okay got it you got
oh it god they're all hot
oh
oh my god
so i've heard you say that all the
makeup in the world can't make up for a
good skincare routine is there an easy
to follow skin care hack that you'd
recommend for a hopeless dude like me
whose bathroom cabinet is basically just
shaving cream and bar soap
lord um yes
god
i
love
like aquaphor i think is great
i wear aquaphor or vaseline around my
eyes every night
i think it helps with
wrinkles and all that that's really
inexpensive and easy
um
i think whatever you do just be
consistent with it and always wear an
spf those are like really simple
things but always wear sunscreen hey
always well if you say khloe kardashian
then it's the truth what are you going
to do
you don't have to if you don't want to
[ __ ]
whatever i'll do it already burned all
night
taste buds
oh god
don't yeah don't say yourself out though
don't take yourself off [ __ ]
okay
cheers chloe what a ride oh cheers what
i'm [ __ ] right okay
oh my god is anyone thrown up from that
never no you'd break new ground okay
and the good news is chloe that we've
reached the final bell here of hot ones
and now that you've worked your way
through the gauntlet and survived what i
want to do is take from your experience
how you think the other family members
would do on hot ones
like tell you what they would do my mom
would kill it but i think kendall and
kylie are very competitive
so they would do it that's like the
gender equality in them
the rest of us would give up
but not you
not you khloe kardashian taking on the
wings of death and living to tell the
tale and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
no
i'm just trying to make it through the
end of this
is this the last question oh my god
what do i have going on in my life
i don't [ __ ] know nothing
like a show or
a clothing line oh
watch hulu
um
and go to goodamerican.com
[Applause]
that was intense oh
do you regret making it about hot sauce
i just ride the wave yeah
if people would want to watch like an
ice cream show with celebrities but i
think people just want to watch
people burn their faces
yeah
but you made it
oh my god i'm so proud of you
sean you're really crazy
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's episode
and i have an announcement to make the
first ever hot sauce for kids hot ones
junior it just got a little bit hotter
you know the green say hello to our
brand new hot sauce the yellow a super
mild hot sauce with sweet tropical heat
from mango pineapple and scotch bonnet
pepper
the yellow it's ready to party with
tacos nuggies heck even ice cream to get
your hands on the newest hot ones junior
sauce visit heatness.com.com.com
to pick up the yellow